yeah how are you well then I'm
emotionally exhausted yesterday was such
a magnificent day and the Padres owned
all out to send me off in the final home
game and there's so many you know 60
years of memories come flashing through
and they found a seal an old item it
just reminded me again what a privileged
life I've had but how do you there there
are times when emotion gets to me
whether I'm doing my own show we're
doing highlights or I'm at the Olympics
but have you ever had that moment where
emotion overtakes you in a big moment
where you're calling the action well you
try to separate yourself obviously I
mean you're the voice of the fans and
not while you call games with passion
and I like to think that I call the most
of the games from my heart and hopefully
somewhat it connects with my brain but
you you have to remove yourself you
can't laugh too hard at your own joke
and you feel like you've got to step
back but there you know there are
moments where you can't help but your
voice goes up a couple of octaves
because you've got this pin and blow in
such an exciting moment hopefully your
emotions don't interfere with your
repertoire toughest sport to call
baseball no question by far it's the
best announcer game for that reason it's
relentless it's the longest season it
the rhythms of the game which I find
very satisfying and soothing and and
enriched are also the moments where you
have a chance unlike any other sport
where you can interject your own
personality your own knowledge of the
game your the history of the game the
humor of the game whereas football
basketball hockey boxing gymnastics
figure skating and all the other events
that I've covered you're just there's a
docent to carry the fans through the
experience the the video and the timing
and the carried nature of those games
frenetic at times though just doesn't
allow you to insert your own personality
cover the NFL baseball NBA US Open
college football college basketball when
the Olympics what was what was the big
assignment where you all of a sudden
felt like I you just graduated to the
big leagues or you just got called up
well I I guess it would be probably the
most important historically again that I
was privileged to cover that was 1968 in
the Astrodome in Houston when UCLA
unbeaten in the defending national
champions played Houston also unbeaten
number two in Elvin days against Lew
Alcindor 52,000 people at the Astrodome
dollars just proud ever to pay to see a
basketball game and it was televised in
primetime on a weeknight there had never
been a game nationally televised Pro or
collegiate non playoff game carried on
national TV and that was Eddie Einhorn
so tedious a syndicated network and only
because JD Morecambe UCLA athletic
director insisted that I be the
announcer at nine Lorne didn't know me
from a basketball rim and they came me
with Bob Pettit and called that game in
a foxhole on the floor of the Astrodome
because they didn't want our body
started to change in the back seats
behind us so you know we only had our
heads above ground and then that became
I think that the the single basketball
game that catapulted college basketball
into the stratosphere I also did the
Indiana State Michigan State came to
Magic Bird game but that just was the
booster rocket that really sent it
higher into the atmosphere that 68 game
was the most important historically and
it was my first time on national TV so
my friends and fans say you know that
Burger careers going down ever since
he's Dick Enberg joining us Dan Patrick
show what's your relationship been with
Vin Scully
well it's limited only because when
Shelly is working it even when I was in
Los Angeles during the Angels with Don
Drysdale you know we would listen to Vin
Scully I would listen as I drove down
from the San Fernando Valley they
Anaheim Stadium to do an angel because
the Dodgers were on the road so he he
accompanied me in my car and it was a
great luxury and advantage I think
because I was able to hear to the best
who's ever called the game he is the
poet laureate
he's gonna leave a huge hole in our
profession and in baseball with with his
absence and we're all gonna miss him and
that that's just redundant I don't and
and through the years you know we we get
a chance doing games where we're at the
same site that to get together and we
have this last couple of weeks and you
know we commiserate how fortunate we
were that we grew up in the era of
black-and-white radio there was no
television for us to you know steal our
imagination we were able to listen to a
game you could be in a room with ten
others and we also drew our own
imagination ten different games and so
in that way I think we prepared not
knowing we were going to become
broadcasters someday although I think he
always had an intent to be at this game
by accident to me and that you know
video is the powerful tool that that
show that that's the event we just try
to complement it but in radio you have
to list we've said many times paint the
canvas and allow the audience to see it
through our eyes and our emotions and
and that really is the training I
believe in our business to be the best
you can be we also have everybody
praising VIN for what he's been able to
do the longevity and his style but then
we don't encourage anybody to emulate is
it easier said than done to let one
person do it and capture everything the
way VIN does isn't that interesting and
that's what sets him totally apart from
all the rest as a college professor
young doctorate with 27 years old moving
out to coach and teach it what is now
Cal State Northridge yeah I borrowed
from all the professor's I was high
school in college that that I enjoyed
that it motivated me and excited me
about education and I think it's the
same for young broadcasters they can
pick and choose from different
broadcasters today but how do you do
that with Vince Tully I mean he was he
was he was this poet that was able to
describe and story tell and use his
intelligence in his command of the
language I guess the only way you could
emulate him as you study hard you'd be
and Phi Beta Kappa talent and
prepare you know to this day he could do
a game blindfolded but he'll go I'd like
to be at the ballpark early I like to
think throughout my career I've worked
the rest and I'm excited about the
preparation that's part of the joy of my
job but I'll go to Dodger Stadium he's
already there he's there for hours
before the game I thought I'd be the
first one and so you can't over prepare
and I think for this day he's he's just
been such a motivation and inspiration
for all of us what's your favorite story
from the show sports challenge that you
did back in the 70s there that old
enough Patrick to remember I loved it
and you know trying to figure out the
athlete and the silhouette there at the
very end and then you'd have I think a
couple of times somebody right away said
that's Bill Russell and then you know
they got it right but you had you had
athletes yeah a team let's say the
Yankees would have Mickey Mantle and
whitey Ford and I don't know if Billy
Martin was on there and then they would
be facing another team that had you know
three other athletes on there and you
were asking them you were the host
asking them questions but I have to
imagine that there had to be some
entertainment going on I don't know if
there was any drinks being
sports challenge but do you have a
favorite story well there was a libation
or two this year we had the beauty of
those shows and I never asked for a
single autograph can you imagine every
calling in every sport we did over 100
shows and we would do three in a day at
the KTLA studios in Los Angeles
Hollywood and so we had to have 15 great
athletes there but at 3 aside for that
meant you needed three teams plus an
extra that's 12 and then three mystery
guests 15 and what was interesting is
the those that competed in the first
telecast and lost they didn't leave and
go back to the hotel they stayed around
in the green room for the second sports
channel and show the finish and then
they waited until at the end of the day
here we are with some Hollywood honeys
and lots of drinks and and they just
stayed and Here I am a fly on the role
of Walter young guy and and just
listening to the conversations and
Raymond Berry's talking with Joe
DiMaggio and Bronko Nagurski is talking
with the the greatest pole vaulter in
the world or whatever and I can remember
even these great athletes someone would
say well I've gotta go and that we had
limos to take him back to the beautiful
Roosevelt Hotel in downtown Hollywood
and and and one athlete might run after
him and say Ted Williams I need an
autograph before you go it was that kind
of atmosphere
Here I am this this kid in the candy
store observing it all I didn't realize
at the time in the oh man it's like it's
gonna be your career too you don't
really realize how blessed you are now
privileged yaar to be part of so many
wonderful events in a in sports that you
love so dearly until you're able to step
back I guess that's what's happening to
me now gosh I did that too and wow that
was a great experience but at the time
you're getting ready for the next game
you hardly have a chance to assimilate
the way you've just experienced yeah I'm
trying to do a little more of that it's
just it's hard in the moment because I'm
doing this five days a week and you may
do football night in America and then
hand out the Super Bowl trophy or cover
the Olympics it just sort of it goes on
you're on that assembly line and until
you step back and you take a deep breath
and go wow I've been pretty fortunate so
I I do understand it I'm trying a little
bit harder to do that while I can well
you get it embrace it and embrace those
that you're fortunate to rub shoulders
with so much greatness and it's always
been a tendency because I'm a fan I like
to think I call the games as a fan and
that I'm sitting next to you and in the
bleachers and it's hard sometimes you
don't want to interfere with the
experience or with them there it's
they're being very kind to give you
their time but Nick you were hanging out
with Mickey Mantle and Joe DiMaggio
Muhammad Ali I'm handy I'm hanging up
with these dad's right here in front of
me I mean it's a little bit different
there no that's that's a little
different than part of the experience
yesterday was going through all the
incredible partners that I've had in my
career you know Merlin Olsen and in
football and Pat Haden and Dan Dan Fouts
and bud Collins and Matt
Rowen Everton in tennis and Allen Billy
and Bill Walton in basketball and dick
button and figure skating and okay you
know I'm gonna leave a Johnny Miller in
golf the best in the sport were sitting
next to me and I get to not only get
paid but I had the best seat in the
house and I get to kick the brains of
these brilliant people who have excelled
in their sport at the highest level I
mean how good is that
well good luck and never stop doing what
you love there dick we appreciate it and
thank you for joining us thank you Dan
onward and upward Dick Enberg Hall of
Fame broadcaster he called his last
Padre a home game last night he'll be
calling the Padres last three games in
Arizona but says he's not retiring that
they'd been around a long time doing a
lot of things 10 Super Bowls I don't
know how long he did Wimbledon I'm gonna
guess over 25 years the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience